we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here's a question from a viewer is
merrick garland maybe just waiting to
indict everyone all at once once the
january 6th committee hearings are over
hey david syrup
this is jeremy from new jersey
uh with everything that's been going
on
with the january 6 committee yeah it
seems obvious that trump and some of his
associates
have committed to reason
yet the just department of justice
hasn't taken action against many of
these people
and
personally i'm hoping
that the doj is waiting to take action
at the end of the hearings
in the hopes that
public opinion
will get turned in their favor
but i'm curious what your thoughts are
on that well i have two thoughts first
of all i don't like a department of
justice that's making decisions on
charging people based on public opinion
they should be making decisions and
charging people based on the evidence
that they have so in that case i hope
that what the doj is doing is not
waiting for public opinion for charging
these co-conspirators to be higher that
would be a bad thing
the other piece of this is the truth is
it takes a while for the department of
justice to put together charges they
have to investigate they have to decide
what what are what can we prosecute what
could we get a guilty verdict on etc so
it's just as plausible
that it's not that the department of
justice is waiting it's that
as the january 6 committee exposes
possible criminality the doj starts to
investigate and it can take a few months
to put together what the charges are now
that's optimistically thinking i still
have seen no evidence that merrick
garland actually wants to or is willing
to charge anybody high level in the
trump uh uh
administration up to and including
donald trump i've just seen no interest
from him in doing that and we'll
continue to follow it i hope that
that is not the case but i'm not feeling
particularly optimistic about it we'll
talk on the bonus show today about the
new images from the james webb space
telescope many of you requesting the
story super interesting new york city
monkey pox cases have doubled again
not good and jill biden has now
apologized after saying that latinos are
as unique as breakfast tacos very very
weird thing to say
and we will talk about it on the bonus
show get instant access
by signing up at joinpakman.com i will
see you then